>>Chris: Well, hello, everyone.
My name is Chris Chabot and we're here for
the social web fire site chat.
We got quite a lineup here today, superstars
here within Google who are working on the
Social Web.
We're missing one.
He's gonna be joining us pretty soon but I
figured we'd start with a general introduction.
So if you'd like to all introduce yourself
let's start from left to right.
So DeWitt, if you wanna kick it off.
>>DeWitt: Hi, I'm DeWitt Clinton.
I'm an engineer.
I work on a number of different products in
our developer focus area and a lot of that
overlaps with Social.
I'm also a prolific Buzzer and if you go to
my Buzz feed right now, it's -- you can find
it at profiles.google.com/dclinton -- I started
a thread of people asking questions and you
can feel free to use that to ask
questions and I brought my laptop up and I'll
be reading it.
So.
>>Joseph: I'll take that.
I'm Joseph Smarr.
I'm a Social Web engineer at Google as well.
Joined in January.
Previously I was CTO at Plaxo.
So I've been working on open standards and
interoperability for the Social Web for a
long time and very excited about where we've
gotten, where we're going.
>>Todd: My name is Todd Jackson, I'm a Product
Manager working on Google Buzz and Gmail.
>>David: David Glazer, Engineering Director,
been working on different social things at
Google starting with Open social a couple
of years ago.
>>Sami: Hi, I'm Sami Shalabi. I'm an engineer
on the Google Buzz APIs and Google Friend
Connect.
>>Chris: And if you have one moment. [Laughing]
Then we have our final guest of today.
Drum roll, please.
>>Joseph: He switched into the same shirt.
>>Chris: Introduction.
>>John: Hi. John Panzer, working on Open Specifications
and on the Buzz APIs.
>>Joseph: Mr. Salmon.
>>Chris: Yeah. Mr. Salmon, amongst many other
things. So the format today is pretty casual,
like fireside chats are.
I'd like to remind you if you have any questions
if you could please step up to the microphone,
otherwise we're gonna have to repeat them
and we'd like to start up with just an open
round.
I'm sure that after all the social stuff we
talked about these days you're gonna have
a lot of questions either about Buzz or general
strategy or anything else.
So this is the time to ask them.
So who'd like to start?
Ah. Or I can come to you with a microphone.
It's okay.
>>Manish: Hello. I'm Manish.
I work at OTN Entertainment on the social
platform we are building and then I noticed
in both days, yesterday and today, that no
one is mentioning Open Social at all.
So I wanted to see what is Google's strategy
with Open Social going forward?
Thank you.
>>Chris: David, I think that's a good question
for you.
>>David: Sure.
Actually, the session I came from right before
this was a session on Open Social and Open
Social in the enterprise and some of the attraction
there and
two days ago there was an Open Social meet
up that was hosted by MySpace in the city
with a -- good.
Good.
I would have been there but I/O and the good
thing about scheduling that with I/O is many
people were in town, bad thing is that many
of us who were busy with I/O weren't able
to attend in person.
But Mark and I were very involved in the planning.
So Google strategy with Open Social is to
continue to use it in all the appropriate
places Orchid obviously is heavily, heavily
using Open Social, iGoogle is using Open Social
for all the applications that run on iGoogle,
the various APIs that the wire APIs where
it makes sense for them to be aligned like
PoCo, portable contacts, are a part of Open
Social and part of the Buzz APIs.
So the core underlying standards that Open
Social and the rest of the Social Web are
built on around OpenID and OAuth continue
to be driven pretty hard.
So the strategy is continue to use it everywhere
it makes sense, which is a bunch of places,
and continue to work with all the other folks
who are using Open Social, and other relevant
standards to keep the standards moving towards
– towards the ball and keep the ball moving
towards the standards.
>>Joseph: Yeah, I might just add that, uh,
opening up the Social Web is a
Multi-pronged approach.
There's a lot of different aspects of identity,
and sharing, and on-site, and offsite, and
so forth.
So anyone who's followed this space for a
while knows it's a somewhat messy and frothy
cacophony of different overlapping standards
but they all are aware of each other and trying
to play well together and I think that's actually
good because ultimately it gives developers
a lot of flexibility in terms of building
blocks that they can mix and match together.
So you see, for example, OAuth being used
with Open Social, RESTful APIs, and Discovery
DOC.
I mean, they're all very interrelated and
I think that's a healthy thing that's going
to keep evolving.
>>David: I actually wanna add one point that
comes up when we have this
conversation internally and it really brought
home when we were chatting about it how quickly
things are evolving in the space of the Social
Web and two and a half years ago when Open
Social was first introduced by the set
of companies that the -- that defined that
standard, the hottest thing in the
Social Web was running applications inside
somebody else's site and – and putting social
applications inside a web site and that was
the coolest, hottest, bestest thing.
And it was.
And that, now, is one of many interesting
things happening on the Social Web and it's
far from the middle of the action.
It's just -- it's one of many important things.
So the technology that the – that the Open
Social standards community and -- and the
Shindig implementation has invested most heavily
in really nails that problem and anywhere
that – that somebody is trying solve that
problem, whether it's in the classic social
sense it's something like Orchid in a sort
of extended sense in somewhere like Linkedin
or somewhere like iGoogle whether it's, whether
it's more in an enterprise space which is
the analogous thing where something like Atlassian
has re-factored their entire suite of development
tools based on Open Social.
Anywhere that that is the problem, that is
the answer.
But the social web has become bigger than
that one problem.
So the set of answers is bigger than that
one standard.
>>Chris: And we have one question in the Buzz
as well that was kind of related to it.
What are your experiences with implementing
these fast-moving standards compared to implementing
standards coming out of the standard bodies?
Have there been a lot of interoperability
issues?
Are you having difficulties landing on the
right spec version?
>>Sami: As we were implementing the Buzz APIs,
one of the things that was apparent is there's
a lot of good movement in this standard space
but the standards are still young.
And we're trying to build something that is
-- is immediately useful to people so that
they can do very interesting things with the
-- with the Buzz infrastructure.
However, we've had to introduce additional
extensions to the existing standards and one
of our goals is to try to remove every proprietary
extension to these standards so that it allows
anyone to become a -- a -- a core component
or a core player in the -- in the Social Web.
[pause]
>>Chris: Yeah.
Cool.
Any questions?
[pause]
>>Chris: Anybody?
We go on back here.
If you can walk up to the microphone.
[pause]
>>Audience Member: I was just wondering if
there's any plans for us to see some of these
social applications within the new Google
TV framework.
>>Chris: Oh.
Good question.
Interesting.
Who wants to take it?
>>David: I -- let me -- how -- how many people
in the audience are thinking of building apps
for Google TV?
[pause]
>>David: How many of you think you might build
some social features into those apps?
[pause]
[laughing]
>>Chris: There you go.
>>Joseph: That's one of the advantages of
building on the web as the platform is, is,
does Google TV support OpenID?
Yes, it does.
Why?
'Cause the web supports OpenID.
I mean, I think that's actually kinda nice
that we didn't have to do anything special
to make that work.
>>Chris: Cool.
Next question.
[pause]
>>Chris: Well, while you think about it, I'll
take one from the Buzzes we've been getting.
What are the benefits of using these open
standards?
Do you find that it's more difficult?
Are you slower going?
Having troubles coming up with specifications
with the community?
Are there benefits to doing open or would
a closed system be better?
[pause]
>>David: Yes to all of the above.
[laughing]
DeWitt: That's a saluting question, Chris.
Chris: Yeah, I know.
DeWitt: No.
We hate open here; right? I know.
So the decision was made really early on with
Buzz to, to go all in on -- on the open side
of this.
I mean, I think for everybody here, there's
a desire to see what we're doing in Buzz,
what we're doing in Open Social, implementable
literally by everybody.
So it should not be a Google thing.
So even if it was a little more difficult
and in some cases it is actual actually a
lot more difficult toimplement to a community-lead,
openly-licensed spec, it's an investment that
we're willing to make and we feel like we
get more out of it by investing up front and
saying, hey, let's do Activity Streams, let's
do PoCo, let's do Media RSS. Knowing that
what we'll end up with is a – a network
of sites and implementations rather than just
Google.
So harder, yes.
Worth it, absolutely.
I don't think anyone up here has any regrets
about this strategy.
So.
[pause]
>>Joseph: We do get benefits from it too,
right?
For example, take something like OAuth 2.0
which is being worked on right now as sort
of a next generation way of accessing private
data securely and it's a lot simpler for developers.
There is lots of really smart people outside
of Google who worked on that.
We obviously have been working on it too and
so we get all the advantage of that insight,
all of that field experience, all of that
trial and error.
And, of course, all of the developers who
start using OAuth maybe to work with the property
other than Google and then they come to Google
and realize they already know how to build
that, especially since all those plumbing
layers tend to be the hard part to get right
and it's not the fun part.
The fun part is what you build on top of it
and so I think we absolutely see the benefits
of it as well so that's why I think it's worth
investing.
I mean, no one would think today to set up
a web API that wasn't over HTTP.
It seems sorta silly to ask but in a way that's
kind of what we're building for the social
era.
>>David: I agree with all of that.
The one -- one thing I wanna as add is 'cause
there were a couple of different threads in
that question as asked, is the -- there was
a -- there was a comment about standard and
there was a comment about interoperable and
I -- I wanna say that at least in my opinion
one of those is very clearly a means and one
is an end; right?
The end is mass -- is the maximum choice in
interoperability.
That's the goal, right?
And it just so happens that the best way that
I know or that I've seen in any industry to
allow maximum choice in interoperability is
open standards 'cause everyone knows what
to build and everyone knows that if they build
it they'll be allowed to use it and you need
both of those to be true. And if -- and the
goal is, get maximum interoperability which
is maximum choice.
The means is open standards and that's the
best way we know to get there as an industry.
>>Chris: Cool.
Thank you.
We have a question.
>>Bill: Hi.
My name's Neil.
The Twitter library of Congress deal, that
was the gift that was announced on the 13th
of April kinda got my mind reeling about long-term
data retention. I understand that it's open
and everybody agrees to the terms of service
that our stuff's right out there but that
type of deal could not be facilitated without
a lot of money and a lot of resources on one
side and the other.
So I guess I -- I was wondering if you could
speak to -- particularly on the Salmon protocol
-- if you ever thought of maybe an expiration
tag, something that will allow an author,
at the time of publishing, of posting that
data, to put an expiration on it.
And second -- second of all I guess -- I think
about these things in terms of robots.txt
for web crawlers and that there's a no index
no follow convention and that's on a per page
basis, not just in the robots.txt file as
a metatag.
I -- I just -- I wanna kind of revisit that
idea that there's a possibility this data's
retained forever and that necessarily wasn't
the intention and then the value of that data
beyond the real-time now traveling into stale,
actually, does not – no longer serves a
purpose or could serve a different purpose
in the future for the author than it was in
the context of the real-time to interact.
[pause]
>>Chris: Cool.
>>John: So I'll give a quick answer about
Salmon and hand it over -- there's a bunch
of questions in there. So I think that Salmon
is extensible and you
can put a lot of additional metadata in there
and a potential thing might be a, like, newspapers
have this as stale after X date and we're
going to ask you to remove it after X date.
The one thing about putting data out to the
universe is that once you broadcast it out,
you can't be guaranteed anything.
>>Bill: Sure.
>>John: I mean, that's sort of obvious, right?
It's like sending radio waves into outer space
they're out there potentially forever.
But you can have signals that tell people
how to be polite and how to do the useful
things with your data, and the services that
are well-behaved, if you come to an agreement,
they can honor that.
So the protocols can allow that, you can come
to agreements and then it's up to the services
to, to act on this.
And I think you had a bunch of other questions.
>>Chris: I think that we can summarize part
of his question to one of the things that
Joseph Smarr and DeWitt Clinton both I think
have a strong opinion about, who owns that
data?
Who gets to make the choice of how long it's
retained?
>>John: One sole comment and then I'll hand
it over to Joseph is that I think users should
own their own words.
I've worked on blogger for a long time.
I very strongly believe in that.
And they should be able to make these decisions
in a fully transparent way, whatever the outcome
is.
>>Joseph: I think one of the things is -- and
it's a very complex issue, obviously and I
think I'll throw it over to Todd to talk about.
To me, when I hear that what I think of is
one of the things that's weird about technology
and the communication technology today is
this thing between ephemeral technologies
and things that last, that stand in the written
record has been very blurred, right?
And we see this all time where people use
e-mail very ephemerally and it sometimes sticks
around and gets pulled up in legal discovery.
Or is chat IM -- does that get logged or not?
Sometimes it does, sometimes it doesn't and
why should – is calling on the phone now
or transcribing voice calls are, like -- and
people end up hopping into different technologies
because they have these different idiosyncratic
properties but really that notion of permanence
being per medium is kind of orthogonal, right?
It's more how does the technology work and
what policies are around it?
And that seems like somewhere where we think
about a lot in the context of Gmail where
it's sort of sometimes synchronous, sometimes
asynchronous, sometimes ephemeral, sometimes
permanent.
And so that must be something you guys have
to think about in general, and ditto with
Buzz.
>>Todd: In general, with Gmail, Gmail was
founded on the idea of users
want to store everything for as long as they
want to store it and they shouldn't be forced
to delete it or have to separate from the
thing -- the data that they've produced for
any silly or artificial reason.
I think it is a complex issue and I think
John hit it on the head when he said, if you're
producing data that's in the public sphere,
it's in
the public sphere.
There are hints and ways that you can tag
it to say here's how I intend it to be use.
I think it's a really sort of elegant solution
and we'll see sort of how it -- how it plays
out.
Yeah.
The spirit is that the user -- the user owns
their data and can hold
onto their data, or export their data as much
as -- as much as they'd like.
>>Bill: And I guess that's why I'm asking
the question is to hopefully encourage you
to think about long-term data retention because
we were just at
the cusp of this now and, we're launching
applications and I mean, I -- I was sitting
listening to Chris Messina talk and also the
PubSubHubbub talk and the amount of data – they're
pushing more data than Twitter's pushing?
And so again it's a tiny little piece of metadata
and robots.txt is not a law.
We just obey it because it's a good thing
to do.
And I'm hoping that maybe I can encourage
you guys to think about what can we do that's
good for the people because the providers
don't wanna do it because, I mean, there's
great things that we can do business value
wise for that data to have it long-term retained
but for the users, I just want you guys to
think about them.
[pause]
>>Chris: Thank you.
>>Todd: Great question.
>>Chris: Next question.
>>Bud: I'm Bud Gibson.
I'd like to advocate for a question in DeWitt's
Buzzstream which is, when are we gonna start
to see Buzz-Salmon integration and maybe more
broadly when are we actually gonna see Salmon
doing something?
I'm really enthused about the whole idea.
Chris: I love this question.
DeWitt: I posted the question.
[laughing]
'Dear DeWitt.'
Chris: You're to ask for it as an audience
member.
Joseph: I have this friend –
[laughing]
John: So I think this is a great question.
And I -- thank you.
And, yeah.
And so very enthusiastic about Salmon and
Buzz integration and, I'm obviously -- I'm
Mr. Salmon, I'm working, working on this and
it's something that we hope to do in the -- in
the future I can say that.
We don't have schedules but we're very, very
interested in that.
Yeah.
>>Chris: Excellent question.
>>Joseph: I think I would say I think we're
proud that actually other companies have implemented
even more quickly than we've been gotten around
to.
We've been working on the specs in I/O and
we demoed this yesterday at our Virginia Islands
talk that it clicks set and status net and
others all have this federation, and then
that's awesome.
'Cause ultimately one of the questions came
up before I was going to say is, you know,
is this hard work?
And one of the things is that almost all of
these standards we're working on, there's
not a whole ton of code that you have to write
to implement them.
It's much more around what is the right interface
and what are the right building blocks.
And that can be hard to negotiate 'cause this
is all pretty very complex and subtle stuff
but the total amount of code that you have
to write is usually quite small.
We've all tried hard to work to make these
as developer-friendly as possible.
So
it's neat when people can take a good idea
and just implement it in a day and, we're
trying to move as fast as we can but it's
really cool to see people moving even faster
and it's great to see that enthusiasm.
>>John: Yeah.
I just wanna note on the Salmon side it's
been great to get the immediate feedback about,
oh, this is very easy implement on all these
other platforms that I'm not working on and
this is -- this -- this particular thing was
hard to let's change it quickly.
So that immediate feedback is very, very valuable
and it -- it may mean that the protocols change
a little bit but it makes them much, much
better and so it's an investment that I think
pays off very well.
>>DeWitt: And, the one other thing I'd add
to that is I guess, what, Buzz is about a
hundred days old right now, which is in some
ways incredible, right?
It's a very, very new product and when we
launched it we made a promise, maybe overpromised
but we wanted to reach for it which is that
when we built an API for this we're going
to build it around a number of protocols,
they were actually outside Google's control,
so we said we are going to build this around
Activity Streams, we're gonna build this around
PoCo, and Media RSS, and PubSubHubbub, and
OAuth, and Atom, and AtomPub and just sorta
promised the world and, that's a -- that's
a gutsy thing I think to do as a company 'cause
of course that landscape can change on us.
So here we are a hundred days later and yesterday
we launched the first iteration of the public
Buzz API and it supports PoCo, and AtomPub,
and Atom, and OAuth, and Activity Streams.
We haven't implemented Salmon yet.
It -- it is our plan and hopefully we can
-- we can live up to all those promises that
we made early on.
So, I'm actually amazed and I know it's Sami
and his team's work that -- that built this
API and I'm a big fan as a user of it.
And so.
>>Joseph: Yeah.
John and I checked in just enough code to
get the shirt.
They did all the hard work.
[laughing]
[pause]
>>Chris: So just to mix things up a little
bit, I'm gonna ask a question where I kind
of know the answer already but we're hearing
it a lot at the Google I/O.
What is the difference between Buzz and Wave?
And I think Todd, you can do a good job at
explaining this.
>>Todd: Buzz and Wave are, are two products
that are good for communication and sort of
different flavors of communication I would
say.
Wave is a product that's -- that's very, very
good for collaborative, working
environments and people working on -- on things
together.
I think Buzz has a little bit more of a sort
of social and sharing flavor to it.
It's integrated into Gmail which is a -- which
is a place where people are sort of talking
and chatting and sharing things already.
So I think it's sort of a strategy of Google
saying, we're gonna invest in two products
that are both communication products but sort
of different flavors of communication products
and seeing how users use them; what are
the ways that they're interesting and different
from one another?
>>Chris: And going down the road, do you see
a point where they would become more integrated?
>>Todd: It's certainly something that we're
open to. Yeah.
And in fact, the two products while they don't
share code they do borrow a lot of ideas from
one another.
So
one of the things that you saw when we did
the version of inbox -- what we call "inbox
integration" in Buzz where you get these sort
of live e-mails that come right into your
inbox, people comment on them and they sort
of drop down in real time right in place.
So some of these -- some of the ideas -- things
that we saw happening in Wave we moved over
to Buzz.
>>Chris: Awesome.
Anybody's got anything to add?
DeWitt, you looked passionate for a moment.
No?
[laughing]
Okay.
What's going on around social network federation?
And I think that kinda touches on Salmon but
it's a bit of a wider question when you think
about identity, relationships, pictures, everything
else.
So it's a very open question so anybody who
wants to dive in and give their opinion.
[pause]
>>Joseph: Yeah.
I don't know how many of you were able to
come to the talk that John and I gave yesterday
on bridging the islands but I think, besides
getting to see Chris Messina's awesome artwork
-- look for it.
If you haven't seen it, it's really cool.
I think that metaphor is one that really resonates
for us and we've actually talked about it
since the days of Open Social that, you first
need to be able to get a bunch of islands
speaking a common tongue and then you can
bridge those islands and really let people
live and travel wherever they want and have
it just work.
And the metaphor we were trying to go for
in our talk was that if I go move to a new
physical location, I should still be able
to stay in touch with my family and friends
and I should still be able to share rich information
with them.
You shouldn't feel impoverished because you
want to go live in different places and that
-- that feels like the right way for the
Social Web to evolve.
It's -- obviously it's how e-mail has evolved.
You can use one e-mail provider, I can use
another one.
It's how cell phones work.
It's how a lot of these communication technologies
work and -- and that allows for that innovation
and that user choice.
And so, that's why, again, open standards
interoperability really make that possible
if
I can show up and say, hey, I've already got
an account here with OpenID and OAuth.
If I can use WebFinger and say, here's where
else my stuff lives.
If I can share information richly with PubSubHubbub
and Activity Stream so I don't have to dumb
it down or slow it down to go between sites.
If I can then participate in conversations
even when I'm not in the same place as you
using Salmon.
These technologies all are bridging the islands
and that, I think, is going forward exactly
how we wanna keep things going.
>>Chris: So I'm gonna combine this with one
other question we've got in on the Buzz stream
and that is, when is Buzz gonna support OpenID?
>>Joseph: In which direction?
>>Chris: As a login option.
>>Joseph: As a relying party action.
I mean, that's -- that's definitely the direction
we're trying go.
As we've said in the past, Google actually
already is -- you're talking about being an
OpenID relying party which is, say, in coming
with one of your existing accounts, we already
have to do this with a lot of our enterprise
customers because we run apps for your domain
on lots of domains that often have their own
login systems.
And so obviously there are a lot of complexities
associated with that but we've been trying
to really eat our own dog food there and figure
out how to make that work and of course I
think it has a tremendous application in the
consumer space as well.
[pause]
>>Chris: Anybody wanna walk up to the microphone
or shall I take another one from the Wave
or Buzz?
[pause]
>>Chris: Ah.
We got a question here.
Cool.
[pause]
>>Audience Member: This is a question on the
namespace situation. I think it's still the
case that if I open a Buzz account, I'm either
gonna reveal my Gmail address or I'm gonna
have this giant number that nobody understands.
So how's that moving?
And also, any clarification on finally moving
Buzz out into its own stand-alone product
separate from Gmail?
>>Todd: Both really good questions.
So yes.
Buzz currently does use the Gmail namespace.
We thought that was the best way to start
things off and it makes sense that I own a
certain name in the Gmail namespace and I
wouldn't want to lose it, right, and to have
someone else to come in and claim it.
So we're still working on some of the issues
that have to do with that but we've heard
loud and clear that people -- the long stream
of numbers at the
end of your profile is not what people want.
They want a name that's friendlier and easier
to see so we're trying work on that.
And your second question was on a stand-alone
Buzz site outside of Gmail.
That's also something we're definitely interested
in.
We've heard loud and clear that people want
to come and try this product and they don't
necessarily need a new Gmail address in order
-- they don't want a new Gmail address in
order to do that so it's something that we're
working hard on.
[pause]
>>Chris: Chris Messina, you have a question.
[laughing]
>>Chris Messina: Yeah.
Hey, guys.
So I'm actually curious in terms of the relevancy
stuff that you guys do in Buzz right now.
How's that gonna appear in the API or will
I be able to dump a bunch of stuff at it and
use it in my own apps?
Because one of the things that's interesting
on the one hand, of course, is you get this
Activity Stream of all this stuff in chronological
order.
On the other hand, my experience in the Buzz
App has a bunch of condensed stuff and things
that I imagine are gonna be made more relevant
to me over time based on different signals.
So how can that experience I guess be made
portable for other people to embed in their
external apps?
>>Todd: That's a really good question.
This is something that actually we're in the
middle of making many, many changes and improvements
to.
So today the way that it -- Buzz works when
you view it inside Gmail is that it's sorted
by the last comment time.
So any time someone leaves a new comment on
an item it jumps back onto the top.
And the reason we did that is because we really
like the conversational nature of Buzz.
We want things -- the items to be engaging
and involve conversation.
We are in the process of re-thinking that
some.
One of the things that we really want to do
is, is we want conversations to come back
up to the top when they're interesting to
you.
So because somebody that you're following
left a new comment, because the combination
of activity that many people have done on
something makes it significantly interesting
to pop back up to the top for you.
So I think you'll see a lot of development
and sort of what we call -- we call this "bumping"
and "personalized bumping" and it's something
we're gonna explore a lot in the future.
While also -- another thing that we've heard
from users is, I just want the purely chronological
view by post time stamp.
So we want to also give -- offer, like, multiple
ways to view the Buzz stream, sort of slice
it and dice it.
And you'll see these corresponding changes
are happening into the API.
But this is an area of really -- I think of
strong interest from the Buzz team.
It's something that we're passionate about
and it's something that you'll see us explore
a lot.
>>Chris Messina: Thanks.
Chris: Cool.
We have another familiar face with a question.
[laughing]
>>Robert Scoble: Robert Scoble.
I keep thinking about malleable social graphs
and the first one that showed me that -- the
power of that is foursquare because if you
check in here, you only see people who are
near here.
Now, take that and there's two different pieces
to this question.
One is, when are you gonna hook up to the
other data silos in the web, like foursquare,
like tripIt, like other things that I'm showing
the web by my behaviors.
My liking behaviors across the web, not just
on Buzz.
That's one problem.
And another problem is, how am I gonna discover
new people based on their expertise?
For instance, if somebody's visited four barbecue
places in Austin, they've automatically set
themselves apart from the crowd and become
an authority on Austin barbecue and I might
want -- if I'm going to Austin or if I wanna
talk about barbecue, I only wanna hear from
those people.
I don't wanna hear from the rest of the people
who have no freaking clue about barbecue,
right?
And who haven't demonstrated the system that
they're an authority and credible on barbecue.
How are you gonna build this malleable social
graph to both let us discover new people and
see content only from people who are authoritative
and credible on -- on the world?
>>Joseph: So I think the question was, do
I like barbecue and the answer is, yes.
[laughing]
>>Joseph: No, I –
>>Chris: So how could Robert discover you?
>>Robert Scoble: Are you credible on barbecue,
and if you are, I wanna see your, like.
>>Joseph: Right.
Right.
I'm a credible consumer of barbecue.
>>Robert Scoble: But if haven't been to four
barbecue places, don't show me your thoughts
on –
>>Joseph: Totally.
I -- I very much agree with everything you
said.
When I talk about bridging the islands, one
of the things that -- not only is it so let
users have choice to use the tools that they
want but it's so that individual tools can
really special in individual social experiences.
I think foursquare is a great example of something
that, by being its own experience, it can
really nail that experience and I actually
choose to associate with a different set of
friend on foursquare than I do on the other
tools I use.
But of course I want that to then enrich the
rest of the things that I do.
And that's honestly it's just something that
for us has been very early days but that's
absolutely the -- the -- the payoff of allowing
all these different sites to flourish.
You wanna make it really easy for me to go
to a place like foursquare and quickly sign
up and find my friends and so forth and then
to use all that check-in history of me and
my friends to inform me back on Google.
It'd be nice to see it on Google Maps and
everywhere else.
So that's the one thing is that I think absolutely
the more that there's two-way data flows,
the way everyone wins, really.
And then the second point was using that not
just based on my current social graph but
actually based on interest and authority.
I don't have anything particularly smart to
say about that.
Maybe other people can.
But I guess that I would point out that by
making the data open, one of the things you
let people do is re-mix it in different ways
like that.
So maybe Buzz is gonna have one way of presenting
data to you and that may or may not be appropriate
to try to pivot on other axes but if the data's
available, other apps can try to do that and
I think you've seen a lot of that in the Twitter
ecosystem where they'll take it and provide
a completely different view that's not based
on time line but it's based on keyword or
based on a set of people or location and I
think that's a great example of the kind of
innovation you can unlock when you let the
data free.
>> [Asking question in the background]
>>Chris: So just to repeat the question so
YouTube picks up on it as well,
Twitter has lists as a solution.
Do you consider doing something similar?
>>Todd: Yeah.
The feature request of some kind of filters,
or lists, or groups, something along those
lines is something that we've heard often
and that we're thinking about it and working
on.
Also, just one of the things you mentioned
is just the ability to see what you've liked.
In Buzz, you can't -- I can't see what Robert
Scoble has liked.
That's a feature that we're launching very
soon.
Hopefully like next week or so.
>> [Asking question in the background]
>>Todd: That's correct.
Yeah.
So I think -- yeah.
Interoperability is -- is –
>>Joseph: You can imagine pulling those images
APIs for that stuff.
In theory, all this stuff should flow and
you should be able to aggregate it all together.
>>DeWitt: We just call those activities, right?
The action of liking some entity is an activity
and then, as we develop protocols like Salmon,
those activities can be federated.
So you could imagine a world in which starring
something on twitter or liking it in Facebook
gets propagated to you on whatever network
you're on.
>>Joseph: It's also a good use case for Activity
Streams, right?
Right now, almost all of the syndication between
web sites is just RSS and atom which really
don't have innate notions of things like location
or liking and Activity Streams do.
That's exactly the kind of richer semantics
you want so that I know that a geo located
check-in can be on any service and I can still
aggregate it
around a map or that it's a like and I can
aggregate that, or it's a shared
link, or it's a photo.
You don't have to do a custom integration
on a per-site basis.
>>John: And, to follow on that, one of the
benefits to users of going and doing all these
things and building up this data and making
it open in some cases just totally public
is that they built up a reputation and the
fact that they -- this stuff is actually linkable
to each other is a feature in these cases
because you can -- you can build up a reputation
as the best person to talk to about barbecue,
and it doesn't matter which service it was
that you used and it really shouldn't because
if you built a reputation somewhere, you should
be able to carry that.
It should be a portable reputation.
[pause]
>>Sami: One additional point I'd like to add
to that is, I mean, we're in a space where
the -- we have a theories on what the answers
are going to be and if you have ideas or things
that you wanna build based on the social infrastructure
that -- that we're building and it's -- and
what we're building isn't -- doesn't make
that available, it'll be great if you reach
out to us so that we can figure out ways to
make -- to help you build these very new innovative
use cases because not all innovation is going
to come out of Google.
The beauty of – of having APIs is that everyone
participates in -- in innovating in this space.
So please reach out.
>>Chris: Cool.
Next question.
>>Audience: Yeah.
I feel, like -- first of all, thanks, guys.
And it's terrific work and it's great to see
all of the new improvements as well in the
progress.
But I feel like there's an elephant in the
room and it's about to hit 500 million users.
Where are we around Facebook and Facebook
Connect and Open Graph?
Right?
Would Google -- would you guys ever think
about putting a Facebook Connect button on
your sites?
If not, why not?
How -- how could all of the work that you
guys are doing also inter-operate well with
this enormous monster that's down the road?
[pause]
>>Chris: Who wants to take it?
>>Joseph: Yeah. Yeah, no. It's -- it's obviously
a great question and it's -- it's one where
I think there is a lot of good news.
I mean, Facebook's gotten very involved in
a lot of work on open standards and there's
just this internet identity workshop this
week which has been kind of the grass roots
place where a lot of us get together and work
on these things and Facebook's one of the
most active and forward-thinking participants
and they -- they -- in fact they shipped OAuth
2.0 as their authentication mechanism for
all their new Graph API stuff even as it's
still in draft they were one of the first
to ship Activity Streams or in their feeds.
So anyway, there's a lot of different issues
to work out in a lot of different dimensions
but I think it's just great to see that the
platform keeps opening up, it keeps getting
more liberal, and it keeps operating for more
of these interoperability scenarios to take
place.
I think it's a very positive direction.
[pause]
>>David: Thanks.
I'd also add that there are Google apps that
- today, like YouTube, that are well integrated
with Facebook and do auto sharing to Facebook
so, where there are some product by product
choices about wherever it makes the most sense
for users.
I -- I'd also say that, the -- the -- the
elephant in the room, the story of the eight
blind men and the elephant.
Facebook in the area of social, there's many
different aspects and that's why there are
many different answers and many different
parts of it.
And you asked about the Open Graph API but
you actually probably meant the Graph API
which is much less open than the Open Graph
API and it covers a different part of the
space and they're both interesting things
but there's a large -- a large set of details
to talk about.
[pause]
>>DeWitt: One other thing I'd add to that.
David's absolutely right.
There is actually no Open Graph API.
There is a Open Graph Protocol and a Graph
API.
But speaking of open things, I mean, it's
definitely in Google's best interest to work
with Facebook, work with twitter, work with
all of these, these elephants to figure out
what the common protocols could be.
What other things could we build?
Could we build an open connect?
Could we build an OAuth?
An OpenID?
And use all of us working together to help
make the web itself more social.
I don't think ultimately Google does very
well if we get everybody implementing only
a very strictly Google-branded version of
this stuff.
We do much better when the entire web is implementing
the same connect protocol because that's in
our interest and, and I honestly believe it's
in, twitter or Facebook's best interest to
do this as well.
We'll go out of our way to work with 'em on
these things.
[pause]
>>Chris: Could you expand that a little bit
why it's in our best interest?
>>David: What's good for the web is good for
Google.
>>DeWitt: Yeah.
It is so simple.
I mean, our business was born on the web.
It will be on the web forever.
The web is much, much bigger than Google.
The web is much bigger than Facebook.
And to the extent that we can continue to
grow the web, Google as a business does well.
Plus, I think a lot of us here just personally
believe that.
It's not just the business.
Like, we wake up every morning going, hey,
I wanna fight for this.
Like, this is exciting.
>>Joseph: Yeah. I was gonna say, it motivates
a lot of us personally is just, like, it's
a lot better as a user when your stuff works
together, right?
I mean, whether that's your TV and your MP
three player or your social networks.
And particularly for social networks it's
communication.
Everybody's doing different things in different
places.
And so it would drive me nuts if I could only
call other Sprint users on my phone, right?
Or -- or only e-mail other Gmail people.
I mean, actually, that's the way e-mail used
to be.
They had to invent the @ symbol, right?
Right?
I mean, 'cause people were, doesn't it suck
that we can't e-mail these people at Berkeley
from Stanford?
And like talk about the big game.
[laughing]
>>Joseph: So I think we each have to remember
how early we are in this space and how much
turnover there already has been in terms of
marketshare, and new
companies coming out all the time and I don't
see that stopping at all and I
wanna use social on a zillion different web
sites and have it all work.
>>DeWitt: One thing I just wanna add to that
is you say how early we are but how far we've
come.
I mean, it is amazing.
I mean, if you think back just a couple years
ago you had AOL, or Friendster.
These sites didn't federate or talk to each
other at all.
I don't know if they had APIs.
It was not -- you couldn't possibly do it
and now we're at the point where we have these
incredible container formats.
We have Atom, and AtomPub.
We have a notion of expressing these activities.
We've invented WebFinger.
We have PubSubHubbub.
Activity Streams are real.
Like, in -- in just a couple of years we've
gone from zero interop in the social space
to it's almost working, and big pieces of
it already are working.
So if you look at the trajectory -- and I
love looking at trajectories.
It's not where we are now, it's where we were
six months ago or a year before that and where
can we predict we're going to be? In a very
short amount of time, we will have this Holy
Grail of, like, I should be able to mention
Joseph, on a completely different network
from Google Buzz.
It should just work and I predict that that's
-- that's very, very close.
>>Chris: And I'd like to ask for a quick expansion
of that to tie it into a question we had on
the Wave and that is, how do you feel the
Buzz launch has affected this situation?
[pause]
>>Chris: How do you feel that launching Buzz
has driven this forward?
Has it affected the development of the open
and social web?
Has it done a lot of good for these protocols?
Is it a good use case?
>>DeWitt: It changed everything.
[laughing]
>>Chris: All right.
Yeah.
[laughing]
>>DeWitt: Well, it -- okay.
One, it's a social network I like and -- no.
I mean, I think it opened up a new opportunity
for saying how do we do some long form communication.
As a product even I think it was -- and I
can say that 'cause I didn't work on building
the product itself -- I'm saying this as a
fan.
I think it's a very good product.
What I do think maybe drew a line in the sand
was we are going to build the API around -- for
Buzz around open protocols.
We'll take that risk, we'll embrace that challenge
and I do think that raises the bar.
I think it forces other companies to maybe
justify why they wouldn't use a open protocol,
if we've proven that it can be done.
>>Joseph: Yeah.
I think it's also just much harder to innovate
from arm's length so I'm really glad we had
this question saying, hey, when are you gonna
ship Salmon?
I mean, how would we ship Salmon if we didn't
have Buzz?
Right?
So I think it's really good to actually have
a platform where you have to work all these
things out and I think -- and the point is
we've taken a strategic attitude from day
one that we want this to be one of many islands
that are well bridged so that it can be great
but it can kinda do what it does and, and
everybody benefits.
[pause]
>>Chris: Cool.
Next question.
[pause]
>>Audience: One of the questions I have, and
I'm not certain it's even a programmable question
which makes it difficult, is that when I think
about just the way I interact with people
in the real world, I might be friends with
perhaps this person over here and I really
respect his opinion about coding for example
but I think he's a complete idiot when it
comes to health care.
And over here, this guy also knows him and
they agree on health care but they don't agree
on coding.
So it's like for myself, it's like for politics
and stuff like that --Republican versus Democrat,
people have different people that they respect.
So the person who's gathering the most global,
shall we say status around health care may
be someone I say, no.
I want to actually do a not operation.
Or anything that he recommends I wanna exclude.
>>Chris: Mm hmm.
>>Audience: And -- and with the social space
it seems like just that one party or another
party can kind of pollute the tag space if
you will and dominate the conversation.
We saw that on Digg with all the Ron Paul
fans.
And -- and it just seems like there -- there
needs to be a way -- as much as we wanna talk
about private versus public it seems like
there needs to be, like, a series of publics
if you will.
And the thing I liked about Wave is the idea
of a federation models built into Wave and
it seems like there needs to be some sort
of federation model built into how we talk
about not privacy per se but how far we want
the information to spread.
>>Chris: Okay.
I think that's a valid question.
I think there's actually a few questions in
there.
It's how should these trust relationships
be federated between different services?
And the other question I heard is, should
you be able to express these trust relationships
and have 'em reflected in the servers?
>>Todd: Well, the part of the question that
I really found interesting and something that
I think about every day and that the Buzz
team is -- and Google in general is passionate
about solving, is an information problem.
Thinking he's an expert in one thing and she's
an expert -- she's an expert in another and
wanting to see that perfect stream of information
where you see the stuff that you find incredibly
relevant and known, and known and interesting
experts and things.
I think those are the kinds of problems that
Google needs to solve.
>>Audience: Or experts defined by me, not
–
>>Todd: Exactly.
Exactly.
Well, in that it's personalized and that you
see the information that you care most about.
And so I think we're -- we're very, very early
in this space but that -- that kind of information
problem is the kind of information problem
that gets people at Google really, really
excited.
So it's something that you'll see us working
on.
I can't really say more than that.
[pause]
>>Chris: Okay.
Thank you.
Next question.
>>Audience: Yeah.
I wanna bring up kind of I think a related
point to what he just described which is I
actually have different personas.
I think I have four or five twitter logins
and they do very different things, okay, and
I interact with completely different people.
I interact with a different set of people
on Buzz than I do on twitter, any persona,
and I interact with yet another group on Facebook.
Facebook is the gym buddies, and friends from
30 years ago.
Buzz seems to be people thinking about social
networks and oddly, twitter is internet marketing.
So, and so I'm doing that and I'm sort of
thinking now that I've been doing Buzz for
a while I -- I've been sort of thinking, well,
this is actually more of a medium than a place.
To be perfectly honest with you, I think of
Facebook as a place.
Buzz seems to be more of a medium.
Have you given any thought to this issue,
which is, I'm actually multiple people, and
-- and at times I -- the people I interact
with would like for me not to be gym bud when
I'm talking about social networking.
>>Chris: I think we have a good question here.
>>Joseph: Yeah.
I think all of you asked good questions.
[laughing]
All right.
I'll leave that one as an exercise for the
reader.
[laughing]
>>Joseph: You're absolutely right.
And one thing -- this is a common I think,
the thing we have to be careful when we talk
about that the ability to link together your
profile and sources of data doesn't mean you
should have everything all into one big lump.
Quite the opposite.
It actually gives you the freedom to be as
fragmented or unfragmented as you wanna be
and right now the problem is everything starts
out completely separate.
So for example, this is something that comes
to my mind a lot, when I come to a conference
like Google I/O, I run into a lot of people
that I've met before and it's actually kind
of a neat feature of the brain that, I like,
can remember that I met them before, maybe
in a different context, and then make a decision
based on the current context and my prior
relationship whether I wanna also engage with
them here or engage with them differently
and maybe I'll talk to Google employees differently
than old friends, versus colleagues etc.
But the point is, there's a link there.
It's not you're a completely new opaque identifier
in a new data base and I have to start from
scratch.
And I think that speaks to Robert's point
as well that he asked earlier.
You're gonna wanna develop these nuances and
so you're gonna to want to have that fluidity
of not being afraid to go someplace else and
start over but still bring in maybe I wanna
know who I know on this site and then choose
not to share with them or maybe I do wanna
be -- have completely separate accounts that
aren't linked together at all and that's fine,
too.
And actually right now because there aren't
good ways of linking accounts together, sometimes
people have to resort to these more heuristic
methods and that's actually -- that's when
privacy lines can get crossed, right?
Where you didn't want things to get correlated.
But if you have an explicit way of saying,
here's how I want things to be correlated,
then it's much more explicit that when those
aren't there, you don't want them to be correlated.
So I think that's actually going to help both
sides of the industry.
[pause]
>>John: Just one other -- one other thought
about this is, it's not only what you want
or what you decide.
It's also what your friends decide.
So if your friends have decided they're gonna
be on Facebook and they're doing internet
marketing on Facebook but you wanna be social
on Facebook – on Facebook, that's kind of
a problem.
It's -- it's hard to make this work and when
you're since it's actually two ways and so
I think that having some -- having a mechanisms,
especially common mechanisms, that let users
decide, let people decide how they want to
present themselves to the world and not how
to be tied to the service is really important,
especially as – as everybody gets on these
services and people start to use them for
slightly different purposes.
I don't think that the services can all align
with everybody's social desires.
That's -- I don't think it's actually possible.
I think they can -- they can help people present
themselves the way they do in real life where
they have real social connections and they
can make intelligent decisions.
[pause]
>>DeWitt: And just one thing that I think
underlies what John's speaking about is what
we all need to do, not just Google, is, is
provide users the tools in which to both develop
these social spaces and also understand what's
going on, on the web.
So you think about the different networks
and how they're linked.
We need to surface that and make that relationship
transparent into empower the user to make
smart choices.
We always want them to have informed consent
when -- when they participate in these environments
and, what's interesting about it is, I would
actually rather -- I hope this isn't too controversial
-- I would rather Google --
okay.
So you could imagine a world in which there
are a million small social networks and they
all worked pretty well together.
I would rather that world than Google be,
have a billion users and be the dominant social
network.
And -- and I think that that speaks to our
need to let our people, us, have those different
spaces to use and say, well –
>>Chris: Thank you.
So Mark, hello.
You have a question.
>>Mark: I sure do.
So we talked about improvements in the Buzz
API, things like Groups, we talked about bringing
these things together.
How do you intend to advance the industry
by engaging things in, like, Open Social which
you guys were very active in, to bring the
industry together and forward, not just Buzz?
>>David: That's a good question.
There was a -- there was a similar question
before your -- before you came in and I referred
back to your previous session, actually, as
part of the answer.
I think -- no.
No.
That was not a -- that was -- that was a -- that
was a plus.
That was a – a part of the answer I think
is something that Sami has talked about a
bunch which is the idea with the Buzz APIs,
and DeWitt was hitting this point a lot, is
that they are standard APIs, that they are
open APIs and they're based on open standards
and where that's not true, it's because we
didn't know how to take the standards as they
exist today and solve the needs of Buzz and
every time that Sami and his team did something
that wasn't lined up with an existing open
standard, they did it with the intent of saying,
we think this could become part of the standard
and we commit to changing the Buzz APIs to
match the correct standard once it stops moving.
I think I early on had a conversation with
DeWitt and with Sami about this and I started
black and white because it's just easier and
said, why don't you just implement standard?
And they said, because it doesn't solve the
problem.
And I said, okay.
Well, what fraction of it does?
And it was roughly a third, a third, a third.
It was a third where what the Buzz API needed
to do to expose Buzz was well-spoken to by
some existing standard and for that just used
it.
And there was a -- another third where it
was well – what the Buzz API is doing is
an area that just isn't spoken to by any standard.
It's just green field and we're gonna invent
something that feels like it's a good proposed
extension.
And then there were other -- another area
where, for some complicated reason, and each
one went off, we can't do it the way the relevant
standard says and we need to propose that
the standard move towards something that.
And that's been the plan and I think something
we've tried to be really clear about in the
messaging Buzz API early users is, this is
going to change because it's going to change
to become more standard with some version
of the API moving and the standards moving
to come together.
>>DeWitt: And then the other thing I'd just
add to that really quickly is,
there's no Buzz protocol.
I mean, very important that we reposition
it that's why -- 'cause this is how we're
building it.
There's Buzz the product, it's the thing you
see in Gmail.
There is the Buzz API but that's really just
the collection of other protocols.
And with regards to Open Social, we managed
to pull together with Open Social in industry.
I mean, there are so many participants.
We managed to get IBM, and MySpace, and Yahoo!,
and all these other, I mean, really hard-to-get-together-people
in the same room.
Everybody got in the same room and we not
only agreed on actually really impressive
specification but we agreed to a governance
model.
Like, how can all of these companies work
together to build common intellectual property.
I think that's pretty phenomenal.
What I hope to see is that, you know, what
we're doing with the protocols around Buzz,
or Wave, or all these other – other products,
they will get folded into Open Social, and
vice versa.
[pause]
>>Joseph: Yeah.
Just quickly, one of the things that I'm most
excited about from the Open Social perspective
is I feel like Open Social actually designed
a pretty good set of RESTful APIs which is
how you interact across different sites with
Open Social sites and yet they didn't really
get their fair share of the attention early
on because there was so much focus, as David
said earlier, on the end app experience.
But Buzz is also trying very hard to do that
cross site interoperability and it's no coincidence
that the Buzz APIs look a lot like Open Social
APIs --sometimes exactly the same, sometimes
a little different.
And in particular, we always knew that the
activities part of the Open Social RESTful
APIs were a little primitive and a little
weak because things like Activity Streams
really hadn't matured yet and I'm hoping that
since that's sort of the core of what Buzz
does, it's really gonna help us get that right
and in turn inform Open Social and because
we designed them similarly, that translation
of technology's gonna be really simple.
So that's a kind of the way we're thinking
about how to make this all work together.
>>David: Just making that tangible I would
love to see Open Social 1.X RESTful API be
exactly the same as what the Buzz product
supports at the time that that API exists.
And that will take movement on both the product
and the API but I -- but that's very much
the intent is have that model of -- of, of
API governance apply.
>>Chris: Okay.
Cool.
Next question.
>>Female Audience Member: Hi.
I love Buzz.
Thank you. And I am just wondering, there
are people I follow who bring up topics that
I'm not particularly interested in, similar
to what somebody else mentioned I think, and
I would love to be able to use the same kind
of filtering that Gmail already has, specifically
–
>>Todd: Ah.
>>Female Audience Member: -- on Buzz so that
I don't filter out an entire person but just
– I don't wanna hear all the political
stuff or I don't wanna hear the abortion debates
or whatever.
And can -- are you gonna be doing that?
>>Todd: From Joseph, mine is political.
[laughing]
>>Todd: Filters of that power, --
>> [Asking question in the background]
>>Todd: It's, it's a great suggestion.
We are working on various ways to filter.
That would be more -- one of the more powerful
ways of doing it.
I actually hadn't thought of that.
>>Joseph: It would be cool if you could actually
do topic-base clustering and actually try
to guess, does this sound like political speech
-- kinda like Google news did or something?
>>Todd: Right. I don't know.
>>Joseph: We have some, like, smart machine
learning people that we can throw on that.
>> [Asking question in the background]
>>Joseph: Yeah.
>>Joseph: That could work, too.
You have an idea.
>>Audience: So, I wanted to come back for
a moment to talking about correlation and
privacy because frequently as we imagine how
we can make these transparent -- make these
systems transparent, the management of them
becomes incredibly onerous.
Right it's like if I wanna go to Facebook,
for example, boy, can I tweak every setting
and it's unlikely that I ever will and frankly
there are times when you're pretty sure they're
gaining on that.
So I guess the question that I would put is,
how would you imagine that we can actually
have that transparent informed consent as
not only we're coming into a more and more
complex social world on the web but as we're
discovering new uses after the fact.
So after I've gone through and managed it
very carefully, oh, you've just invented a
new way to use that data.
[pause]
>>Joseph: There's no simple answer but a couple
of -- couple of thoughts.
One is, it seems to me that you're gonna have
to start to have tools that help you manage
some of this stuff and the -- the interoperability
in open standard is kind of a prerequisite.
So here.
Let me give you a good example.
As I mentioned earlier, I recently moved from
Plaxo to Google and, I'm
a pretty, like, with it, savvy, tech guy on
the web but I can't tell you the number of
web sites that still say I work at Plaxo 'cause
I don't even remember all the sites I signed
up for let alone had a chance to change my
job title on all of them.
Now, I wasn't doing that because I wanted
to have multiple personas.
It's just broken and if those sites all support
the kind of basic APIs, one place you might
look is the Mozilla Labs guys have been doing
great work and they have the specification
of an account management API where a site
could describe, here's how you programmatically
login and log out, here's how you programmatically
change basic account information.
If you imagine something like that existed
on all those web sites, maybe my browser or
a web site could help me see all that and
change all that information in one place.
And you can imagine doing similar things with
privacy settings; right?
If you could make the privacy options portable
so that if, for example, I block somebody
on one site, maybe that should follow me to
another site which of course then means I
have to know that it's the same person on
another site.
So you just can't solve any of those problems
without these standards but once you get them,
there's all kinds of wonderful value adds
like that on top that you could build.
And maybe this'll be a place that smart browsers
can really help us.
'Cause after all, they're the ones that are
really sort of intermediating
that.
>>Chris: Cool.
Next question.
>>Audience: Advertising.
When does the social team talk to the advertising
team?
Will we expect to see more about the integration
of these technologies next year?
Never?
One of the two?
>>Chris: [Laughing] That's an A or a B kind
of question but what is your general thought?
>>David: Principle is -- the principle – it's
gonna sound – it's gonna sound trite but
it really is the starting principle.
When we thinks it makes things better for
users and -- and that is, that there are ways
to do -- there are ways those two teams could
talk that would be very bad for users and
there are ways they could talk that would
be very good for users, right?
And -- and that means it's -- that means it's
not -- we're not gonna rush anything in that
area because it's -- there's some sharp edges
in there and we're not gonna do anything imprudent
but at the same time it was -- I forget which
of the CEOs in the keynote this morning said
he would prefer to see ads for Lexus than
for diapers when he's watching TV.
And, and I understand that preference and
it would be a very -- that -- that's an example
if you could get that right where you actually
could help users a lot by -- by doing things
like that and the advertising team with things
like the -- the interspaced stuff that's going
out there and is -- is -- is dabbling in that
to see what's good for users.
But -- but the -- the full answer is longer
and more complicated because there are a goods
-- goods and bads.
>>Joseph: I would also just mention, one of
the things I do a lot in my social
interactions is tell people about the products
I'm passionate about and that is, that's sort
of a form of advertising and it would be nice
if it were easier for me to not only share
the products that I'm passionate about but
follow products that I care about and I just
had -- for example, every time a band I love
I realized, oh, my God, they released an album
a year ago and I didn't hear about it, like,
everybody lost there, right?
And so it seems like there's lots of opportunities
there that, where the two come together very
naturally.
>>David: Let me -- let me ask some questions
here to -- to just calibrate people a little
bit.
Suppose that -- and this is completely hypothetical
because we don't talk to the ads team.
No.
[laughing]
This is in the -- this is in the realm of
–
>>Audience: You think they're advertising
people at Google?
Really?
[laughing]
David: This -- but this is in the realm of
thinking what are some of the really good
and really bad things.
Suppose -- suppose that there were a preference
you could set somewhere in your account at
Google that said, take advantage of the information
on my profile to change the ads that I see.
How many of you would check that box?
Okay.
Suppose there were an option that said, take
advantage of what my friends are doing online
to change the ads that I see.
How many of you would –
>>Joseph: That they've shared with me.
>>David: Yeah.
[pause]
Yeah.
I'm being intentionally squishy here.
It was interesting.
There were less hands.
Y'all had to think.
That was interesting.
Okay.
Here's one.
Take advantage of the contents of my e-mail
to figure out what brands I
might be interested in and change the ads
that I see when I'm surfing the web.
How many of you would check that box?
Only – only in a very narrow way.
And -- okay.
So my point here isn't to actually -- this
isn't market research, right?
[laughing]
This is -- this is not as a -- but I'm -- I'm
just trying to give you a hint of the kinds
of interesting questions, right?
I was most interested in the speed with which
hands did and didn't go up because -- because
I have to think about how I would answer each
of those questions and it depends on the details
whether it's a good idea or a bad idea to
do each of those.
>>Chris: Cool.
>>Joseph: I don't know.
I heard "ship it".
[laughing]
>>Chris: Okay.
So because Buzz is such a new product and
we recently had the Buzz API launches, I'd
like to ask Todd ask Sami to give their closing
thoughts
on how this has been going and then we have
to stop in about ten seconds.
[laughing]
>>Chris: Yeah.
>>Audience: So you caught my ear with the
digesting of a corpus, I mean, the body of
whatever Google has access to.
What about something involving maybe, like,
a realtime approach where you have maybe deep
back an inspection>
Are costs given content in real-time as opposed
to the corpus?
And I know you guys serve up AdSense but what
if there was a way to say, where I know you
are, how I've classified where you may be,
what you may be doing, what your gestures
might be, and then how that might affect what
might get served up.
Is that something you might be interested
in?
>>David: If we could get it right, that would
be very useful.
I mean, I would love to have ads that were
that interesting to me.
>>Audience: Yeah.
>>David: And it's harder.
>>Chris: So, Todd, any closing thoughts for
us?
>>Todd: I would say just from the product
perspective of Buzz, DeWitt mentioned Buzz
is about three months old.
The team set a very early goal to be launching
a feature a week and we've hit that rate.
We've launched 15 new features since Buzz
launched.
It's something that you're gonna continue
to see us do as actively innovate the product.
There's some great stuff coming next week
and the week after that I'm really excited
about.
So keep your eyes open and listening and making
the product better every day.
>>Chris: Cool.
Sami?
Sami.
[laughing]
Sami: So, kind of my thoughts is -- is to
reiterate the fact that, I mean, these APIs
are young and we want -- we really want to
hear your use cases so that we can help you
build great apps, great unique innovative
apps.
So please do reach out.
>>Chris: Cool.
Well, thank you all for being here.
Let's give them an applause.
[Applause]
>>Chris: Thank you for coming to the session.